one member state cannot take a decision
that the European institution needs to
explain something order arrived I mean
declare how far it found its measures to
be proportionate so this is a question
for the lawyers to sort out but I would
like to remind you harness that I mean
European Union is a value based
organization we have come together
because we believe in common values and
these common values deal with our basic
freedoms and if we remember this every
day and on every step which we are
taking we will definitely find a way to
the better future supporting each other
also through this very difficult crisis
I do hope the lawyers agree with you on
that how would you characterize the
health of the EU these days well I think
more than anything else is what I would
call a lack of trust in each other
between member states and between people
the the feeling that I should look after
my own interest because I can't trust my
neighbor now the very very being of the
EU was inspired by the overcoming of
viral nationalism of scapegoating of
creating enemies within the nation or in
next country I think the best solution
Europeans have ever found for this
recurring pandemic of wars that we saw
for sentence is the European Union where
we say okay I can only flourish if
you're doing well I can only do better
if you're doing well this is served
Europe for so many years and and you
know as somebody who's a slightly older
than most of the people participating
today I have
very very vivid memories of being in
Estonia 30 years ago literally 30 years
ago when Estonia was fighting for its
freedom and if you if you look at the
stoner today one of the most modern
countries in the European Union one of
the most connected countries globally a
country leading in tech if you had told
me 30 years ago that Estonia would be a
leading member of the European Union and
of NATO I would have you know advised
you to go and see a doctor and now it's
just a reality and everybody sees it as
normal this is a huge achievement and
it's done on the basis of values and and
your president is one of the persons
leading on values in Europe and I think
she's doing an incredible job of that
when you look at the initial reactions
we saw isolationism we saw protectionism
what can you offer what kind of a recipe
can you offer for the heads of state for
the governments in this situation to get
over that to remind again those values
that brought us together and that made
us stronger you know the cope with
crisis was upon us in the blink of an
eye and everybody needed to react to
save people from dying and getting very
sick but then step by step we can offer
a way out of this crisis that is more
efficient if we act together as
Europeans that if we do it individually
so I think if we can offer a prospect
that starts from three principles first
our reaction should be commensurate to
the challenge so if we see that for
instance there's almost a trillion of
investment gap we should be able to
react to bring your back in into a
growth situation secondly we need to do
it fast but this can't wait because the
economic effects will start being felt
very soon and especially after the
summer the the specter of mass
unemployment will become really looming
and thirdly we need to do it in a way
that is based on solidarity that those
countries that
suffered more and have less capacity to
invest themselves out of this problem
get the support of the countries who
suffered less and have more capacity to
come out of this crisis then we will be
in line with the European principles and
then I think we can show to our citizens
that working together delivers better
results than trying to do it alone
Direct is a great word I'm just
wondering how we learned the lessons
from 2009 when the past economic crisis
the financial crisis southern European
countries felt as if they were left
alone do you feel that the measures
taken now on the European level will
like the Italians the Spaniards the
Greeks they won't feel left alone I
would think that even during the last
crisis and particularly as we now look
back through that crisis and and its
resolution even southern European
countries who need it quick help then
must realize that the outcome not for
them not for anybody in in Europe piece
is too bad I mean we stuck together we
resolved many problems which relate to
our euro area very still business to
finish but we are better off and better
prepared so if we look back at that
crisis and and final outcomes I would
say that we can actually be encouraged
by that experience and indeed we should
seek to act in solidarity and if I hear
people talking about investment gap then
sometimes I get worried because I've
seen a certain feeling that for
development only public money can be
used whereas I deeply believe that
public spending should only be limited
to creating free market opportunities
and then we should leave it to private
sector to build the market and and act
on the market because for example if we
take energy markets in European Union
then we need to make
that there are connections between
countries but then we need to make sure
that no country invests public money
into production and Reserve creation
otherwise the markets ruin for the
private investment and that's the danger
this is our choice no smart policymaking
together we smart investment into market
creation or massive public spending to
carry out the the change in the energy
sector which we need because when the
European Union started based on the
values and then supported by the
economic principles which then we're
well worded in to two words cool and
Steve and now these two words are data
and clean energy so I think we need also
in this crisis to make sure that our
reaction now when the panic has passed
is not limited to while trying to reach
back to the state to score which we have
but also trying to reach forward to the
new economic opportunities when I look
at the word Corona bonds it does bring
back memories from the financial crisis
euro bonds was a much heated debate back
then are we still facing similar
political hurdles when let's say
restarting the European economy these
days and I mean the country you know
best is well very critical towards these
so-called corona bonds will remain
staunchly opposed to it what I what I
fear most is that we address this crisis
in the same way with the same
instruments as we address the previous
crisis that would be a huge huge mistake
we need to understand that to get out of
this crisis given the investment gap
given the huge needs for restructuring
that will affect but there are large
parts of European industry we have to
mobilize as much capital as possible
private and public
is something that will lead member
states to look differently at for
instance also public debt and the
interesting thing is if you look at much
of the country I know best on the one
hand very critical of Corona bonds on
the other hand very very willing to
invest massively and incur even a larger
portions of a deficit and larger
portions of public debt so the thinking
about debt and publicly that and private
debt is developing is evolving the one
thing we need is for us to come together
at a European level and to find a
compromise to what extent we will need
loans and to what extent we will need
grants to get out of this crisis and
that's exactly what we're doing right
now there should be a balance between
loans and grants that can be acceptable
to all Member States we will talk about
the economy more thoroughly in a few
minutes but let's talk about values
Freedom House recently said Hungary was
no longer a democracy how worried are
you about the developments that we see
in some countries in Europe when in the
shadow of the crisis certain let's say
powers are consolidated president
calculate well as I said already
European Union is a value based
organization it cannot be impressed
based in principle because our treaty
says each and every one is equal and we
know that if we are in an interest and
power based world then the small ones we
suffer we have voluntarily agreed to the
treaty which says each and everyone is
equal each and everyone has their rights
this applies for States which applies
for citizens this applies for groups
among our citizens this applies for
journalists and everybody European Union
cannot exist without these foundations
and and it can't change if we start to
change this and say we are only an
economic cooperation we are not anymore
a value based Union then I'm afraid that
we will lose the grounds of coming to
the common decisions relating to our
future because the grounds of decision
making is our treaty always has been
and we'll always be most president
timmermans your take on this well I
couldn't agree more with president
calculate on this I think she is
absolutely spot-on also for the reason
she gave but there are also purely
economic reasons you know if we want in
the internal market to function if we
want our common currency to function we
need to be sure that all the laws we
decide in Europe all the regulations we
decide in Europe applied in exactly the
same way all across the European Union
and we need national parliaments to have
the possibility to look into that and
ultimately we need national judges to be
able to be European charge when they
judge that and if we we have a problem
with the rule of law if judges are no
longer independent if Member States can
determine by themselves how to interpret
EU law then sooner or later the internal
market will break down and the common
currency will break down so we also not
just it's not just about fundamental
values for which you know your country
fought so hard thirty years ago it's not
just for that it's also because for the
very functioning of the European Union
we need to be on the same page in terms
of respecting fundamental values and you
know just a couple of days after you
know the freedom of the press day was
held a democracy cannot cannot survive
in a way that is in line with the rule
of law if there are no free media if the
media are turned into first state-owned
media and then state propaganda
spreading media and and I think we have
a challenge here not just in the EU but
why do in the world to make sure that
our journalists can do their work free
and fairly without interference from
government well I do thank you for that
support mr. timmermans I don't know
about you but in the past days I've been
eager to check out flights from
different airliners to see if there's
already something available for Italy or
Greece now
what is your scenario how do we keep how
do we keep free movement alive this
summer in the southern European
countries which heavily rely on tourism
when can we open the borders there and
what will what will take place in the
European summer this year mr. Timmons Oh
at the Commission we're working now on a
plan to see how we can help tourism and
the hospitality industry recover you
need to understand you know that the
business is suffering most in Europe our
small and medium-sized enterprises and
in the tourism sector in the hospitality
sector you have micro enterprises and
small enterprises and and and if we
don't come to their rescue if you don't
help them recover then you're looking at
mass unemployment and and huge huge
problems in many member states now the
the main issue here is how you organize
tourism and combine it with the
necessary social distancing and I think
we need to work closely with the
transport industry we need to work
closely with tour operators and we need
to work closely with those countries who
are net net exporters of tourism who
really need this recovery so that we can
get tourism started again and still have
social distancing rules applied then
people can can comfortably go on holiday
without a high risk of being affected by
the coronavirus how do you see the state
of the European economy let's say on
Europe Day 2021 well I was getting a
little bit worried that we are not able
to enlarge each other's perspectives but
now luckily this question well helps me
a lot
I would like to enlarge what was present
immerman said about rule of law helping
also in our economic development take
the two most important areas of economic
development as I already mentioned for
me they are data
and Korean economy if you look at the
data then what you need is for the next
round or digitalization port official
intelligence you need a clear package of
rules which will make sure that each and
every one of us knows who has the right
to a mas data who has the right to mine
data how they need to keep data safe and
how they need to dispose of it and also
how can if necessary authorities verify
that this is indeed happening
we need this regulation urgently because
otherwise our artificial intelligence in
Europe will be less developed and in
less democratic regions and countries
and this we don't want we cannot afford
it so indeed we need a certain quick
development in an area of law at the
European level because doing it
nationally has absolutely no sense data
well this is so so common is the same
green economy where I can see as well as
that rule of law which would make the
market believe that our objective no
emissions by 2050 a huge market
distortion in itself will definitely
take place which will allow them in this
set framework to develop new
technologies and implement them safely
for both citizens investors and also for
administrations because finally we all
held responsible both economic
development and for the respect respect
of our people's rights and also for the
for the respect of our businesses rights
when is the European Commission coming
out with a review proposal or for the
next MSF because sure you can have
regulations but you also need to have
money to get the European economy
rolling again and is the Green Deal
still part of it well soon the president
from the line is working hard on this
with all my colleagues and I think we
will be ready in a matter of weeks to
present this to the European Council and
the
on your second point I believe the Green
Deal is the best growth strategy we have
for you now we were talking earlier
about the need to mobilize as much as we
can investment capacity to get out of
this crisis but this will be by
definition a limited capacity because of
the economic crisis they're not solved
so we have to make sure we put that
limited capacity into the 21st century
economy not into the 20th century coming
because if we do it put it in the 20th
century coming into fossil fuels and
things like that we will not have the
investment capacity to take us into the
future and since we are now going to put
an extra burden on the shoulders of our
children we have to have a proposition
that is good for them and the only
proposition that is good for them is to
deliver a planet that is cleaner that is
more imbalance with itself that leads to
sustainable energy sources that leads to
a circular economy that leads to a
digital economy for which Estonia is a
leader and you know it's also a question
you will have to address in Estonia I
know it's it's not an easy question to
address where do you want to put your
limited investment capacity into where
you were a leader the digital economy or
into the services economy or in to
fossil fuels I think I would reconsider
that very very seriously and look for
ways out of this that takes Estonia also
into the remit of renewable energy you
have huge potential there as well and I
would really advise you to take that
that seriously and to not sink money
into assets that will be frozen in the
future there is no future in coal there
is no long-term future in oil we need to
understand this but there is a future in
wind and in solar and especially in
hydrogen well it would be interesting to
know if the Prime Minister and the
Minister of Economy are with us at this
moment and took your suggestions
seriously but I would like to thank our
audience who have joined us in our
virtual conference room you've been
extremely patient and I would like to
now hand over
floor to you for your questions we have
a question from Poland asking about the
recovery plan and climate so I believe
we should have guessed Poland I got a
question
president T Merriman's if you if you can
answer how do you see the recovery of
the EU member states how it should look
like to make sure that it will not be
focusing on GDP growth because as far as
we experienced GDP growth is fueling
climate change and biodiversity loss so
[Music]
also a question that arrived via the
slider app UN emissions cap report 2019
says emissions must fall seven point six
per person per year starting 2020 due to
Corona
it might be feasible how to continue
this trend the next year and another
question looking at the plans the EU
member states have for restoring a new
normal life is combating the climate and
ecological crisis prioritized enough
these are the questions all sticking to
climate so you have the floor thank you
very much
I honestly believe that the best growth
strategy a long-term growth strategy for
the European Union is to embrace the
fight against the climate crisis and
moving towards renewable energy Poland
is the case because Mario I presume is
if you look at the issues of air quality
and
by University in Poland you see that
important are no longer willing to
accept that bad air quality we lose
400,000 Europeans prematurely every year
they died prematurely because of bad air
quality to do something about that we
need to get rid of coal and you know if
you talk to people who I'm a grandson of
coal miners if you talk to people in
coal mining regions they understand this
they know this the only thing is how do
you give them a perspective in the new
economy and I think there is a
perspective I think you know if you look
at the uptake of wind energy in Poland
now it's a huge economic opportunity if
you look at the possibilities of
offshore wind also in Poland in the
cooperation for instance with Denmark
it's a huge opportunity solar likewise
the services economy the circular
economy Estonia is also leading in this
by the way so I would I would not say
that we need to get rid of economic
growth to be healthy again I think we
need a different sort of economic growth
and in our calculations there are more
jobs to be gotten in renewable energy
sectors than in the fossil fuel sector
and this is where we need to head in
terms of the emissions we need to commit
to climate neutrality by 2050 and then
we need to commit to a certain goal by
2030 we are now at the Commission
working on an impact assessment to know
exactly how to get to our 2013 target
which is - 52 - 55 in terms of emissions
related to what the emissions were in
1990 we will come out with our impact
assessment in September and once we've
done that this can be translated also in
the national plans of governments but we
really really need to make sure we
continue this reduction of emissions
because the corona crisis might have led
to reduction of emissions in this year
but if our calculations are correct and
we will have economic growth next year
up to 6% or even a bit more than of
course image
we'll shoot up again if we don't at the
same time stimulate in the growth of
sustainable energy also like to
contribute on this yes I have to go
quite long back now into history when
you stated that regulations are fine but
money is better may I remind you MF f is
just 1% of the European Union combined
diety GDP 1% it's much more important to
achieve the goals which vice-president
Timmerman sees stating countries which I
totally agree with regulation take
climate the only thing which we need to
do is to convince markets people those
who have money those who have ideas that
we are dead serious about saving this
planet the only way to save this planet
is that the richest biggest market which
happens to be the European Union takes
the responsibility to say and then not
to have I mean little roads aside this
subjective to say we will be clean by
2050 only this will unleash the
development in the wind energy only this
will unleash the development in the
hydrogen we have to make sure that our
market is airtight no dumping we have to
make sure that that will be also no
green washing of meat on this is a fuel
which is phosphide I'm sorry to say yes
coal is bad and gas is better but we
need to make sure that we will replace
for example in Estonia and in the
Nordics the polluting energy production
with wind this is what we need to do and
we need to convince markets by
regulation that we are serious about it
we have people queuing up for more
questions first off I would like to hand
over the floor to mari orchid astok we
have you on the screen go ahead thank
you and I think it will follow exactly
in the same line as the previous topics
discussed I would maybe like to talk
about the hydrogen sector that also has
quite significant developments here by
Tartu University and kbf I as well as
well
nice production facility here in Allegan
namely in Estonia we have our electric
electrical supply safety well in a
question and at the same time we need to
also go for the greenhouse gas
reductions and that should also lead as
well put also to the natural gas
production in urbanization to combine
the hydrogen and the natural gas
questions in the at least in the nature
by attaching fuels and technologies to
the current gas lines so instead of
burning the gas we would actually be
doing it without the carbon emissions
and producing electricity by a hydrogen
in it this is a technology which already
exists but is available at low scale so
what is needed is basically scale-up of
the productions but this is a situation
that the free market cannot currently
foster so to do it we would need
something similar to how it was done for
the PV panels etc we need some kind of
subsidy or other means of investments to
boost it to a scale where it becomes
self-sustaining and I don't think
Estonia can do it alone so I was going
to address the question there is it a
moment to see if this would be something
that could be supported at the EC level
ok vice-president absolutely I think
this is the spot on analysis I have seen
what is happening in Estonia and is very
promising
we will prioritize hydrogen as the
energy source of the future also as a
storage facility for renewable energy we
will develop projects such as the 2 x 40
gigawatt production of by hydrogen and
indeed it's it's it it's also it helps
us in the transition you can blend it
well because we start of course with
gray hydrogen moving to blue hydrogen
and then into green hydrogen that's what
we need to do and then you can blend it
with natural gas and step by step take
us out of fossil fuel as a president so
correctly said and how
has a future also our infrastructure we
have huge infrastructure for natural gas
in Europe with relatively modest
adaptation much of this can be dual use
also for hydrogen and then in the future
it can be used for hydrogen so I think
hydrogen where your leads is really the
energy source and the energy storage
facility of the future and if we need in
this we will also take other parts of
the world near to us in the same
direction there are huge plans for
hydrogen production green hydrogen
production in northern Africa for
instance I know that in the Gulf states
they're thinking about the post-oil era
and also thinking about how to's in
there so this is indeed the fuel source
of the future indeed we will need
investment and we really need the
knowledge that is available in Estonia
to be onboard I would like to add to
that that all we know about the future
energy systems is that the production
will be much more intermittent with
solar and wind which means that then we
need to store this energy which has been
produced and what hydrazine other means
should all be acceptable for us and
should all develop path under the market
conditions what I would really like to
avoid it is that we will choose
politically which kind of technologies
we will support I think all we need to
decide this we will support everything
which is green and let them freely
compete freely developed for example
here in Estonia and by I really
appreciate and value what el cocaine is
doing on the other hand I don't know how
well our own and other Eastern European
gas grids can tolerate hydrogen what is
the percentage of hydrogen which this
gas grid can right now
well consists take in and this is
something indeed where I think we should
create an European Union project to come
and analyze how much of renovation is
that the gas grid is needed in order to
make all these gradual developments to
happen and and I am quite sure that this
has to be a trans europe e'en project
not an Estonian or Baltic or in Nordic
project thank you very much I will now
hand the virtual floor to Christian
you have arrived on our screen Christy
go ahead thank you to the speakers for
this stimulating discussion I would like
to broaden the debate and ask about the
global dimension of the corona crisis it
is as may know a global problem and what
we have seen during the crisis is really
painful lack of global leadership the
universe is not really anymore
taking this role of global leadership
China is behaving irresponsibly tensions
between major powers are growing and
where does this leave the European Union
which has taken some steps to forge a
more global international response to
the crisis it has that some support
slowly to fight with the virus it has
given some help to neighboring countries
and Eastern Partnership matrix in the
Western Balkans but if is that enough
what does the crisis due to the global
role of the EU it's very much needed but
in looking because of our own problems
we decline it to which we were talking
about earlier it's one field where it is
absolutely necessary to also have a
global role thank you thank you very
much Christine vice president
your take on this well I think this is
an incredibly important point and I
would from a European perspective
specifically would want to mention
Africa as a continent it's our sister
continent where we will have to have an
approach that helps Africa avoid the the
worst consequences of
Korona crisis in combination with
helping Africa to tackle things like the
locust infestation they have and the
drought problems they have and their
need to first of all get into the energy
into supplying energy to their citizens
but then let's try and make it
sustainable energy at the same time so I
could not agree more with the idea that
this is a global this needs a global
approach now we're being challenged
because China is now flexing its muscles
more than ever before on the global
scene there is a tendency in the United
States to not be as engaged on the
global scene as before and these two
things combined mean that Europe will
need to take a greater responsibility
for not just its own destiny but also
for maintaining as far as we can the
international system based on
multilateralism and on rules that apply
to everyone now in the one area where I
believe this is still it still has
potential it is indeed on climate change
we are preparing now the next cop which
has been postponed which will take place
in Glasgow and if you see that the world
is step by step coming together on this
but we need still to convince the
Chinese to go further but if you also
see that with the United States even
though the federal government is not in
favor of these developments we work very
closely with cities and and the states
in the United States to make things
really move forward this great optimism
at least as far as I'm concerned that we
can actually have a real result in in
the next cop in Glasgow in terms of our
commitments to the Paris agreement but
let me let me end where I began we have
to look very closely at what's happening
in Africa and take collective
responsibility to help Africa avoid the
worst now in this crisis thank you very
much president would you like to comment
yes
in direct answer to Creasy I would like
to say that all deficiencies in all
societies
or simply enhanced in in the time of
crisis they are brought out but they
were there before and we've never been
perfect or never pretended we are
perfect and we never will be perfect but
also all the trends which were going for
better future also still there for
example if I take the same example as my
president African Union has decided well
slightly postpone because of the
foreigner crisis now to execute the same
four freedoms what we have in Europe
Estonia has a digital memorandum with
African Union for Digital development
standardization etcetera the tendency of
regionalization of making sure that
regions are able to well not not to not
to incur unnecessary
well environmental cost of transport
really cheap boots the regionalization
was already on going to I mean if you
think about the three-dimensional
printing etc these are the trends which
were ongoing these are the trends which
will all work also for the better future
and for the leadership well if you are
working on supranational level like is
vice-president timmermans and and
everybody in the European Commission
then your job is to use the technology
and the positive trends to maximize the
global well-being not only the
well-being of a particular nation or
well-being or a particular country and
they are starting to do so and all I
think that what we need in all this
solution is good healthy dose of
idealism we need to remember why we do
politics and why we do supranational
politics to maximize the well-being over
human beings globally if you are a
supranational level at least this is
expected from everybody thank you very
much president now the microphone in our
virtual conference room will now be
handed to Ivar Reich who is on the
screen go ahead mr. Reich you have the
floor yeah thank you very much I would
like to congratulate everybody on Europe
stage tomorrow and my question is to
mr. France Timmerman's first when next
conference on the future of Europe will
start from spires LaVon Lyon and how
civil society and European institutions
should work there as equal partners
promised a lien and which are the main
ideas to this conference federal Europe
as described by the hofstadt I have his
last book printed in America or by even
crust F who said that there is no future
for federal Europe anymore after this
crisis that the new model of
intergovernmental cooperation should be
worked out
thank you very much thank you very much
Ivar we have a very similar question
that arrived via slide oh I will just
read that out loud the question is as
follows do you think that the
coronavirus crisis will give an impulse
to the conference on the future of
Europe vice-president you have two
questions you have the floor yes well
the minister's is looking into the
planning of the of the conference on the
future of Europe and you know I was a
member of the European Convention I can
tell you if we don't succeed they're
engaging with larger parts of the
population this will again be an
exercise you know if we don't have a
conference along the old lines I can
assure you that I will know every single
participant and every single
contribution because it's always the
same people doing that and that would be
a mistake so my colleague Shwetha is
working on it to make sure that this
leads to abroad
especially in society but having said
that frankly I believe that the only way
we can get the attention of the European
population and we can get support for
the idea at the idealism of the European
Union is if we deliver results on those
issues where nation states can no longer
act on their own where they need the
European bat mention and this is if we
can show that we have a way forward out
of this crisis based on solidarity that
we will leave no one behind not the
weakest people in our societies nor the
weakest countries in our Union and if we
can show that we have an answer to the
climate crisis if we can show that there
is a future for a sustainable economy if
we could show that Europe can play a
global role to avoid new Wars coming to
avoid parts of the world sliding into
misery I think that is the strongest
most strongest way in which we can
create support for the European project
I honestly do not believe in the vision
of giving off start that Europe will
eventually develop into sort of the
United States of Europe I don't think
that is in the nature of who we are as
Europeans we the European construction
will in its nature be hybrid we will
share some competences in a super
national level at the European level
other competences will stay in the hands
of the Member States and you know I
honestly believe strongly believe that a
strong Europe needs strong member states
with a strong sense of identity because
you know if you are if you are sure of
your own identity if you feel
comfortable with your own identity you
don't fear anybody else you don't need
to scapegoat anybody else you don't need
to become a virulence nationalist hating
others just to feel better if you are
assured about your own identity and your
own destiny you're open to others you're
curious about others and you don't fear
others that is how I would like to see
the european union of the future
president colloid your vision for the
future yeah I think I would like to
react to evil rights person and also to
give it off that position on federal
Europe I mean they are opposite
positions but in my mind they are
totally unnecessary positions because
taxonomy is only needed if you have a
high number of similar entities which
are somehow need to compare and classify
but you don't need taxonomy if you're
talking about unique entity and European
Union is unique so we should actually
concentrate on on developments which we
need and not how we classify how the
Union thereafter looks from some
theoretical viewpoint if you look at our
problems in the Union they are common
take it climate big data big migration
whatever programs are conmen even though
we wish to resolve global problems is
common in the European Union for that
rational thing is to have a set of
regulations and agreements by which we
come together in to set place set people
who are supposed to participate Prime
Minister's other ministers a set of
rules by which we come to conclusion and
the way to implement our conclusions and
decisions and if somebody can tell me
how we could individually better achieve
these things then according to the EU
and EU treaty then let me know but I
have not yet heard any at least any
rational ideas take for example how we
globally try to solve the climate issues
or the human rights issues we don't have
a set of rules by which we do it and we
don't have implementation bodies and
that is why we globally fail and of
course that will always be this way
because it would be too much to expect
to manage but at least on our continent
we have managed to come together with an
agreement on how we do things on all
that continent and this simply makes
sense call it maths call it physics call
it well Clawd nature even if you wish
this is how it is and that's why your
opinion has a future well thank you very
much for those bold answers and
statements both of you we now have Syria
disappearing us in our virtual
conference room Syria go ahead you have
the four
thank you I have a question to mr. B
moments when I'm a manager of Estonia
who need of State Association and I have
a specific question I expect from the
European Commission in recovering from
the colleague 19 crisis maybe it's too
concrete the question but I'd like to
hear the answer thank you thank you very
much Syria let's go ahead vice president
well I think you know look at this
crisis European agriculture in the food
industry has been able to feed all
Europeans during this crisis and I think
I think they should be recognized as
part of those heroes who are helping us
to come through this crisis now I think
one of the effects of this crisis that
Europeans will be much more focused on
their health on their consumption habits
especially on their eating habits and
they will want to look for a healthier
food and they will want they will have
more attention for locally produced food
they will want to know how food is
produced and where the elements come
from and I see this as an incredible
opportunity for the food industry but in
the short term it is clear that in
certain sectors especially the
hospitality sector there are serious
serious problems we need to we need to
address and get the economy going as
soon as possible concretely the
Commission will come out with farm to
fork and our biodiversity strategy on
the 20th of this month and there you
will see elements to make sure that we
sort of reconnect Europeans with healthy
lifestyles with hell
food products that we help farmers
produce closer to market with less
pesticides with less negative effects on
our biodiversity and I honestly believe
that by supporting these developments
also concretely in reorienting parts of
our common agricultural policy towards
that we can create a new relationship
between European citizens and what they
eat which is to the profit of the food
industry where where so many people are
working and now I've threatened of being
unemployed and we have an urgent urgent
need to support them to get out of this
crisis would you also like to comment
this yes first of all I would like to
remind us all that Common Agricultural
Policy in the European Union is the
biggest support for each and every form
particularly in smaller member states
with smaller budgets because this
current is that the companies are
treated equally nobody is able to
outweigh the other governments in order
to create advantages for production for
selling for their own companies this is
I believe a big help for companies in
Estonia and elsewhere but I think we
should never forget that second in this
crisis we have seen how diversity of
production has come together with
diversity of demand because all of a
sudden many people move instead of going
to a huge shopping mall or shopping
online and if you shop online then you
have access to far more diverse market
and this is something which definite
they will survive into the future
question is how will the big
distribution chains come into this game
because right now we see it also in
Estonia and I'm sure everywhere else in
Europe all the in efficient delivery
change have actually come up to serve
people with the diversity of production
from Estonian farmers and and part of
the Estonian farmers but the others as
well now how will the big distribution
chains come into matching this demand
because in principle it's quite easy to
imagine that the small form
delivers its produced to a big consumer
chain which will only take upon itself
the responsibility to deliver it at the
other end of it speak to to the customer
and I'm quite sure that since new
digital means as well have been used now
in this crisis to match this diversity
of production with diversity of demand
but these things will continue in the
future and also help the small farmer
short it is of course a very hard time
for all who are producing locally or
producing for bigger markets European
Union is keeping the goods market open
which is a good thing on the other hand
of course all consumers have come a
little bit a little bit nationalistic
and patriotic and this is also I believe
understandable but this cue is not
enough - or not too big - to create much
disturbances in the in the long
perspective
well Celia I hope you got an answer for
your very concrete question I would like
to thank everyone who's participated so
far we still have a quick reminder of
the slider code you need to enter first
of all head to slide doh and when you
get there just enter the code hashtag
webinar oh wait oh five where you can
post your question and we've received
many questions let's just take the next
one so how can we support families and
children in the post epidemic society in
order to cope with everyday life and
solve the mental health problems of
children let's just take that answer
from vice-president trans two moments
our values our values which also mean
that we stand ready to help those who
are most vulnerable who in this crisis
under threat we see across the European
Union a huge increase of the
stick violence in this crisis and times
of social distancing and you know that's
why international treaties that protect
the weaker that protect the vulnerable
need to be adopted across the European
Union for instance the in Istanbul
convention that protects women against
violence should be adopted across
European Union and by the youth itself
the health care of course let me be very
clear on that it's a national competence
but our citizens don't care whether the
competence is national or European they
want us to do something about this and I
believe that resilient health care
systems is something that our citizens
will demand after this crisis these are
the people that pull this through and
the financing of healthcare systems has
always been a challenge and it's
continue to be a challenge but I think
in prioritizing European citizens will
demand of their national authorities
that they make sure that doctors and
nurses are better paid are better looked
after are better educated and that's the
best way we can serve also those who are
most vulnerable and need medical and
other attention at this stage I suppose
you have a strong opinion on this indeed
I think but in this crisis the social
market economy modern practiced by the
European countries because it's citizens
demand it has proven its value in the
crisis we have vast healthcare systems
which can react in a more or less
uniform way we have also lost network of
social security al Bayt it's of course
falling short if you look at the at the
magnitude of the problem but we are much
better equipped than any other region
globally social market economy probably
is the best way forward into the society
which will also help families and
children for the rest the honest answer
is that we will support and help all
over Europe our families and our
children according to national
preferences and according to the elected
governments political tests and of
course all these reactions must remain
in the realms of of the of Istanbul
convention European treaty party which
is also the acceptance of universal
human rights
cetera but nevertheless there will be
considerable difference it's all over
the Europe and this depends on the
political color of each and every
government and this is how we the
citizens of Europe have wanted it to be
really distributional policies all the
realm of national governments you can
never blame European Union if you are
not happy with these policies and you
can of course go to the ballot box next
time and think more completely about
which ideologies you are ready to
support because in the crisis
politicians react according to their
ideology not according to how many euros
exactly somebody promised in additional
child support additional tension
etcetera this is I think elect a lesson
which we we must remember also from this
crisis you cannot blame a politician for
acting out according to their political
beliefs in this crisis of course they
have to remain in the realms of treaty
constitutions etcetera but otherwise
there is considerable room for manoeuvre
and we have to accept it so we've
covered energy we've covered food we
talked about social aspects of the
crisis we haven't covered culture yet
and I'm glad that the next question from
slider will exactly do that that will be
the European Capital of Culture in 2024
now what role does in European culture
play in reconstructing unity cooperation
and Trust in a post Cove 8:19 Europe
provides presidenta moments at the end
of the day reflection so culture is
about representing the human condition
and if culture reflects our human
condition it reflects our most inner
beliefs it reflects who we are
culturally where we belong
etc etc and I believe if we want to
avoid the recurrence in Europe of people
being afraid of each other of people
hating each other and then of people
bashing their heads again
like we used to do for centuries and
centuries cultural will play a crucial
role if you know your culture it gives
you self confidence and if you have that
self confidence you become curious about
other cultures and the cultural richness
of Europe is what makes us strong being
curious about somebody else avoids you
becoming afraid of somebody else because
then you can learn you can see the
differences and by the way you know the
only way to discover who you are it's to
be confronted with someone who is not
like you you know if you ask the fish to
define water the fish will not be able
to do that but take the fish out of the
water for a few seconds and the fish
will damn well know what water is
because it needs it and that's how I see
culture a confrontation with other
cultures helps us better understand who
we are makes us more self-confident and
makes us less afraid of what is
different I know you've been taking part
in a few virtual concerts do you miss
going to the theatre yes I do but I mean
coming from a non packed Rancher like me
but I mean seriously culture is the one
element of our societies which allows us
to understand our society where the
statistical board cannot help you to
understand it thank you very much I do
believe we have our next speaker ready
holding onto the microphone and eager to
ask the question from zoom hello sir you
have the floor Poland I have a question
too but in fact moments how will you go
and see that you've been a union and
state will you and the other person in
business for example Airlines or car
industry
all right twice president do you have
the fall well I wish I could give you
guarantees because most as the president
said earlier most of the money will be
allocated nationally and spent
nationally the only thing we can do is
try and convince Member States that's
sinking all that money
into the twentieth century economy is
going to weaken their potential efforts
to move their society in the economy
into the 21st century so we have to be
extremely extremely careful and I hope
that when we define our climate
neutrality goal 2050 and our goals for
2030 we can then stimulate member states
to translate that into concrete steps to
get to - 52 - 55 by 2030 and that's only
10 years from now so that would mean
very concrete steps so I hope that we
can sort of discipline all member states
to stay on the same roadmap towards this
climate neutral future it's encouraging
that the European Council globally agree
to this the country you are from had
some reservations but we're working with
Poland to solve these issues and you
know not just your movements but general
the public in Poland the citizens of
Poland demand this nobody in Poland
wants to live in this environment where
the air quality is so bad that too many
people become ill and die prematurely so
I am confident that we can collectively
convince everyone to move in the same
direction but let me just end on other
comment that was I was inspired by a
president can you like when she said
people act upon their ideology and of
course there are people who for
ideological reasons want to close their
eyes and close their minds to the
reality of the climate crisis and just
pretend it isn't there and beware of
politicians who deny scientific
realities who deny what is evident to a
large majority of the population namely
that we are in the climate crisis and we
need to address that with great urgency
so we do actually have a follow-up
question for Vice Presidency mermans
when you said there are more jobs in the
renewable energy sector than in the
fossil energy sector
the person asking or comments saying yes
but asks how do you bring the transition
period until reaching this and another
question from slide o EU claims
emissions have reduced 40 percent since
1990 mostly due to offshoring and
importing back into EU by trade now
should the emissions not be measured by
test should emissions not be measured by
destination first of all let me be very
clear this is a global issue and all
only if we we can't offshore our
responsibility that's impossible so we
need to have global agreements that's
why we have the cop in Glasgow next year
and we hope to convince all signatories
of the Paris agreement to commit to
climate neutrality somewhere by the
middle of this century on the and now
I've forgotten the first question I'm
sorry I'm sorry I would repeat the first
question how to bridge the transition
period until we change the situation
that the green energy sector that that
is it every industrial revolution so far
it's not the starting position that's
most painful it's not the end position
that's most painful because that's
always much better than the starting
position it's the transition that is
painful because if if we are true to our
principle of living in a social market
economy we have to be also true in
helping people make that transition that
means re schooling that means lowering
lowering the complexity of working in
the IT sector for instance I've been
talking to the big IT companies about
this it's not just about giving people
more skills to let a to work for you
it's also your duty to make your work
less complex to let IT work and to make
things easier so in this transition some
especially where there are still coal
mines is about 30 of them left in Europe
will have a harder job of making the
transition than other regions
that's why European solidarity should
kick in that's why we need a just
transition fund to make sure that these
regions are assisted in making that
transition and let me just say very
briefly from a personal experience the
regions aren't from the coal mines were
closed half a century ago the last coal
mines were closed half a century ago and
still the region is suffering today
because not enough was done to help the
transition so I know full well that if
you go from a an economic monoculture
that has no future into the future
you have to assist those regions to make
those steps that's why we need a
substantial just transition fund at the
European level to make this happen
again the transition is the difficult
part not to start not the end but the
transition color light would you like to
elaborate on this it was very happy for
discussion from Poland because in fact
if you need to convince people that we
need to go green then it's easy for
convincing governments from one side
indeed we all must collectively convince
each other that we are not going to give
up on our main objective which is
climate neutrality 2050 which already
gives a clearer perspective to the
investment which you were too into the
yesterday's economy and the second thing
is if the citizen demand supports the
politicians ambition to be part of the
green change then the politicians will
do so it's that simple to be honest now
what comes the transitional transition
costs first there are not each and
everybody who now works in coal or in a
stone encasing oil shale sector who
needs to radically relearn a cockpit or
a modern oil shale few world power plant
looks pretty much the same as we look a
cockpit of handling the distributed
energy production from windmills and all
these things these are engineers which
we need in one
case and also in the in the next case
these are the same I mean information
and knowledge which these people must
have in order to run these energy
systems then there are those like - who
probably will need to reorient what they
are doing and for that the best thing
probably is when we are helping people
to move to other sectors initially they
will lose in productivity initially
their salaries will therefore be lower
and we could even consider temporary in
job benefits until people reach the good
productivity level to be able to regain
their earning capacity in new sectors
and if you think of Estonia now then
before this crisis and I'm quite sure
that this will not change the best place
to create new fashionable modern
productive industry has been the same
region where we also have our oil shale
fire power plants so I am hopeful for
quick transition thank you very much
we've received a lot of questions on
energy and climate but let's shift to a
more philosophical approach there is a
question on slider asking is there a
lack of solidarity among the members of
the EU and why is this happening I don't
know vice-president timmermans do you
solidarity is acting in the collective
good with a core of enlightened
self-interest so you need to be if you
appeal to the Solidarity of people you
need to be sure that they understand
that it's in their interest to show the
solidarity as well and there I think is
is the problem today in Europe there is
a lack of understanding that in this
crisis if we don't hang in there
together if we don't find collective
solutions we will knock that out of it's
none of us and so the idea is when you
say well we don't like the attitude of
that country we don't like the policies
of that country they're on their own
they should take care of their own
problems we'll take care of our problems
if you think that is going to
work you are completely misguided and I
wish my my big wish is that politicians
but also businesses who know this even
better than politicians and actors in
civil society would take the
responsibility and go to the citizens
and tell them this look when we are
acting together as Europeans we're doing
it in your ultimate interest even though
you believe you're strong enough to do
everything on your own
sadly you're not we are too
interconnected on a continental scale to
think that individual member states can
take care of this on the road and I
believe if this if this notion
grindingly gets more and more understood
in our society I think solidarity will
not be a challenge anymore because
people will understand we need each
other to get out of this crisis so we
have a window of opportunity now to make
this clear we have a window of
opportunity in the coming weeks to bring
European nations together and let me
know I don't want to sound too
pessimistic but if we fail the
consequences of this are going to be
monumental the illusion to think that
going it alone is fine and everything
else will say the same and the currency
will stay in the internal market will
stay that's an illusion if we fail our
solidarity tests now we will see step by
step unravelling of things we cherish
such as the internal market such as the
values we share such as ultimately even
potentially our common currency so there
was a lot at stake and the revival of
solidarity is an essential element for
us to come out of this crisis stronger
President Kolya Lloyd how do you see
Europe is there a lack of solidarity I
think we saw it only at two months ago
how we couldn't go it alone and how we
couldn't tolerate the people for a week
of going and each and every one better
way I think we should learn the lesson
and I'm quite sure we have learned the
lesson and we will do everything in
order to make sure that our European
freedoms are fully redeliver to us and
that our well economies can
based on that our young people can
thrive based on your asthma sand
erasmus+ all these elements of the Union
Schengen euro I mean we had we had a
chance to feel how it how it was when it
all didn't exist I mean when you
couldn't cross the borders when I mean
trade wouldn't go freely from one
country to another milk prices in
Estonia dropped thirty percent because
the markets down south were closed it's
it's so obvious to each and every one
that it's even weird to think that we
might not learn the lesson I mean I am
always optimistic about the human pilots
ability to learn and and yes indeed
going ahead also making new errors
erring into the into the closed ways and
so also on but materially I'm quite sure
that we got the message well thank you
very much because we have 15 minutes
till the end of our wonderful discussion
I'm going to group the next two
questions the first is a question about
identity what would you do to create a
bigger sense of European citizenship and
do you believe this is necessary to
promote EU values all over the continent
first question about European
citizenship question has Europe wasted
an opportunity of rising as a superpower
after the crisis my president amendments
go ahead well I think our goal is to
contribute to a reestablishment of the
multilateral international system I
think our goal is to make sure the
United Nations can play the role it was
intended to play I think it is not our
goal to try and be a rival superpower
next to a China or the United States
that is a form of rival we can do
without I think the strength of Europe
is in its attractiveness in its societal
and social models I think there is
you know the corona crisis has proven
this again that compare us to other
parts of the world our models of
solidarity I think prove stronger and
more resilient than other models and at
least we don't we don't create the
social habit that is happening elsewhere
because of this and this appeal is the
strongest appeal we have as you're
Europeans and this I think with all the
cultural linguistic differences we have
in Europe I think if you look at the
values we share that comes down to a
form of European citizenship I think
every by and large every European wants
us to live in a society where when
you're old you're taking care of you
don't you slide into poverty where you
have access to education on the basis of
your talents not on the basis of the
money of your parents where if you are
unemployed there is a safety net that
prevents you from sliding into the
property when if you're ill you have
access to medical care on the basis of
fair insurance and that this does not
depend on the money you have you know
all these things combined are uniquely
European and if we see that the in
Ukrainian for instance people waving
that beautiful blue flag with yellow
stars that you can see behind president
candlelight they don't do that because
they want to have access to the Common
Agricultural Policy or structural funds
they do that because they believe in
European values they see these values as
their right to a European citizenship
and we should be more proud of that we
should be promoting that more and we
should see a lot of future in that for
our children and grandchildren thank you
very much president Coley light would
you miss the superpower aspect of Europe
frankly speaking if I have one wish
towards the new European Commissioner
and the upcoming five years then this is
the willingness to be more
tobots our Eastern partners particularly
indeed Ukraine but there are others
those Eastern partners who see the
future as close as possible to the
European Union those countries in the
Balkans who see their future within the
European Union and I deeply believe that
we should also give Ukraine and Georgia
provided by reform provide if they
resemble us in the application of
universal human rights and by and our
democratic values we should give them
also a chance to be part of our family
if this is an ambition of a superpower
yes then I wish this commission
superpower this question what kind of an
outcome do you expect for the end of the
crisis is the EU and what it represents
in danger now I know it sounds a bit
fatal about the person from using sly to
ask this so vice-president timmermans
what's your take on this anything is
made by humankind can be unmade by
humankind especially political
constructs like the European Union so
there is no guarantee that the European
Union will survive any crisis and and
already in previous crises we came close
to a very serious damage to the European
and especially if ideologies based on
viral nationalism based on this idea of
an omnipotent national sovereignty which
in fact in history never ever existed
but this illusion that on our own
ethnically clean we could prevail is the
biggest threat to the European Union
because the European Union is not a
market it's not a currency these are
only tools the European Union is a way
Europeans to overcome the darkest angels
in their history and the darkest Angels
in our history is that we thought we
could prevail by dominating other
Europeans and everybody's tried and
everybody's failed and we have millions
and millions of deaths to prove that so
let's not forget that if we unravel this
project which is unique in our history
we unravel more than a market or a
currency we unravel the possibility of
Europeans to overcome the darkest parts
of our history and to act together where
we depend on each other so much in a
globalized world where you know only the
scale of the European Union can help us
make an impact on the choices that will
be made about the future of the world
president color light as I said for me
EU makes rational sense but I do admit
that in 21st century that is quite a lot
of irrationality in in policymaking and
I think this is playing with the fire
like was playing with the fire flaming
process for every failure even if you
were yourself at all responsible for
that I thought we have learned that
lesson and and I do still hope that we
have learned that lesson and that
rationality also prevails rationality
based on our common values knowing that
indeed power politics cannot bring for
trouble this should keep the European
Union afloat will it be this way well
that depends on the on the proportions
of rationality and irrationality in our
policymaking when a patriot of Estonia
and coming from a small country really
small country of course for us rule
based rules based World Order is is is
extremely important otherwise so it
cannot exist and European Union is is
one of these elements of rules based
World Order so I would do everything to
sustain support and help develop the
Union we're talking about power politics
and the use global position
I'm curious to know is the you taking a
different strategy towards China
something that we see Washington playing
out dramatically France timmermans I'm
from a country that is exactly as big as
Estonia we only have 10 times more
people living there but in sight where
exactly is big so I'm also from a from a
small from a small country you know it
was only a matter of time that China's
economic power would be translated in
its wish to have a global footprint and
to exert its power on the global scale
it's only a matter of time that what
that's when what happens when you build
up economic power and we have to be
realistic about that and I think the
European Council in how it dealt with
China over the last year has developed a
high degree of realism so not ieave
about what China is is doing but not
aggressive in creating a controversy
with China that is defeated for everyone
so we need to engage with China but on
the basis of our values we need to say
exactly where we think the limits are of
what can be done we need to stand up for
our values because ultimately these
values will also be something the
emerging Chinese middle class will want
for it for itself so we have a strong
proposition there but we have to be very
very clear also where we act I feel a
strong response European responsibility
for instance for the developments in
Africa and I say we need to build up a
partnership with Africa which is of a
much higher quality than what China is
doing in Africa because that will be
more attractive for African leaders that
were China is not proposing so I am
absolutely not naive about what China is
doing but I think it would be unwise and
wrong to create sort of a Cold War
atmosphere between the European Union
and China there's no need for that too
with China engaged to strengthen the
multilateral system once again and I'm
sure that at some point the other global
player whose values are very close to
ours United States will come
back to this multilateral system and
assist us in making sure that our value
is the ones we also share with the
Americans prevail on a global scale do
you think they you should take a tougher
stance on China or let's say even go
further in developing the economic ties
Europe has actually a system in place
which makes sure that nobody can
dominate Europe and European markets
this is called procurement regulation
and competition ruling of the European
Union so where other capital comes from
it has to abide by the rules and this
way Europe is already protected from the
economic might and power of China and if
needed we need to expand these rules
into reaching the technology
transparency of technology and keeping
the data safe which which is where I
started this discussion today so
rationally and and reasonably we can of
course talk to China played with China
being adamant that our rules which mean
each and everybody stated equally
applies and this way Europe is safe we
have three minutes
ladies and gentlemen until the end of
this discussion and I would not want to
keep you any longer you've been very
patient and it has been a wonderful
discussion at least looking from here so
I would pose one last question and ask
for your short answers there are I think
two competing visions one saying that
everything will change after the kovat
crisis societies will transform the
economy will change nothing will be like
it was before and then there's another
kind of an approach which will say come
on market-based economy capitalism
democracy we will soon reach exactly the
same society the same habits we had
before the crisis in which of those two
visions do you believe in and let's
start with President calculate I'm of
the school which believes that this
crisis only brought out the existing
both positive and negative trends more
vividly and our job now is to enhance
and and promote the positive trends
to make indeed our economies change and
adapt quicker for the future namely
going clean namely being more data
oriented and data base and of course try
to then make sure that we are able to
control the negatives which also have
been brought out by by this crisis so
definitely this crisis is for
stocktaking
but I know that economy is always
flexible question is will the political
class be as flexible our people well our
people always supporting us making sure
that we maximize the the most important
political goal that can ever be the
well-being of each and every one vice
president will we wake up in a different
world after colvett has let's say left
us hopefully one day will change in many
ways but as the president said we were
already in the middle of an industrial
revolution before coffee
we already faced with an existential
crisis which is the climate crisis
before cold and both the Industrial
Revolution and the climate crisis are
excessive ated by the covert crisis
because the corporate crisis limits our
capacity to invest and to transform so
we will have to have even more focus on
the transformation of our society into a
sustainable society we will have to even
more pool our efforts at the European
level even more invest into
international negotiations to get the
world to come along with this so this
covert crisis will focus our attention
even more on the need to transform will
limit our capacity to act so we need to
use the capacity we have entirely to
take our society and our economy into
the 21st century and avoid investing in
the 20th century economy in 20 century
systems which are going to be obsolete
anyway five to ten years down the road
because of the Industrial Revolution so
I think it just focuses the minds it
makes our activity our actions even more
urgent than before that's the only way
we will get out of this in a way that is
consistent with the values our citizens
believe
vice-president timmermans president
Gareth decoyroid thank you so much for
joining us for this webinar it was very
interesting looking from here and I do
hope for all of you ladies and gentlemen
who have been following us we are zoom
or web streams all across the globe
thank you for being with us have a great
European day tomorrow I hope to see you
again soon
you
[Music]
you